salve a tutti naturalmente lo farò a
modo mio io sono un allenatore uno che
viaggia moltissimo e quindi anche da
questo punto di vista
un testimone fortunato e privilegiato
evasione fiscale che toglie i soldi a
tutti la corruzione che impedisce
naturalmente di svolgersi della libera
competizione dal tra il mercato
premiando i più furbi e non i migliori
blocco dei salari in italia sono i più
bassi d'europa aumento della
precarizzazione sono aumentati i
contratti atipici riduzione al lumicino
e tutto quello che ha a che fare con il
welfare a sostegno di chi è più fragile
e poi ancora il nepotismo la
malapolitica di concorsi truccati le
politiche clientelari sono tanti i
motori molto attivi nel nostro paese che
negli ultimi anni producono e continua a
produrre diseguaglianze sono così tanti
che poi non c'è da stupirsi se nella
redistribuzione della ricchezza privata
abbiamo scoperto che il 10 per cento
degli italiani possiede il 50 per cento
tutta la richiesta sto parlando di
ricchezza privata sto parlando di una
qualcosa a che fare intorno ai 9.000
miliardi di di euro cioè il 5 volte
l'ammontare del debito pubblico quello
che invece stupisce è la mancata
percezione di questo disastro e finché
questa manca la percezione lo fa la
politica va beh ci siamo siamo abituati
ma quando questa mancata percezione
attraversa tutti noi cioè non ci
rendiamo conto del danno terribile che
stiamo costruendo per noi e per le
future generazioni il blocco che stiamo
costruendo lo sviluppo economico proprio
dovuto alla diseguaglianza allora c'è da
interrogarsi io li voglio
siccome lunga questa storia mi voglio
portare indietro in esperienza che ho
fatto nel 2002 andiamo insieme in costa
smeralda e questa è la scena che ci
troviamo davanti abbiamo un palcoscenico
a cielo aperto dove i ricchi mettono in
scena la loro ricchezza è il molo di
porto cervo centinaia di metri con i
yacht e barche
davanti a questo palcoscenico si muovono
migliaia di persone che non sono i
ricchi che però guardano i ricchi vivere
li guardano talmente con tanta passione
che diciamo alimentano questo modo dalla
mattina fino a mezzanotte e scattano le
foto e dietro questo palcoscenico poi ci
sono quelli che moltiplicano queste foto
e consentono l'estensione di questo
con scenico anche ai milioni di italiani
che in quel momento non stanno lì a
porto cervo e sto parlando dei paparazzi
che fanno le foto le finte foto dei vip
erano gli anni dove la gente andava
pazza per alessia merz qualcuno
ricorderà alba parietti siamo la barale
umberto smaila flavio briatore e stava
con tommy campbell quindi questo aveva
provocato naturalmente centinaia di foto
e pagine sui settimanali
erano gli anni in cui lele mora stava
costruendo il suo impero economico
perché lui li ha affittato di un
lobbista con intervistato per un per due
mesi una villa ha detto ci aveva messo
tutti i vip e questa e muoveva queste
truppe cammellate nelle feste a
pagamento lo faceva mi ha detto se un
imprenditore vuole organizzare un mega
party con bb mi contatta mila a 50
milioni di euro di dire era a quel tempo
il rimando chi vuole una serie di ho
visto votare su un panfilo di un
rampollo che purtroppo essere sparito
pigna si chiamava 2011
gente come zucchero infatti mi sono
anche domandato ma come mai il succo
andava lì c'è gente che cantanti vip
attori che avevano soldi che potevano
fare vacanze in posti bellissimi lontano
da tutti si costringevano a questa corre
di una settimana dei dieci giorni
circondati da non poter neanche fare
colazione della mattina nel tuo yacht
perché c era già lì davanti la famiglia
di torino tutta schierata con i quattro
figli che diceva vedi quello e zucchero
poi ho scoperto qualche anno dopo quando
ho incontrato di nuovo a milano lele
mora perché lo facevano per che lele
mora nel frattempo era diventato del
direttore editoriale di tutta la
televisione generalista
era lui che decideva le sorti della rai
e di mediaset era lui che parlava con i
direttori di rete ed era lui che questa
volta si decideva su un palcoscenico
questa volta sì fondamentale quale
canton cantante quale attore andava in
quello show o in quell'altro fabrizio
corona che avevo incontrato molto un
bellissimo ragazzo sconosciuto a pochi
anni dopo sarebbe diventato una macchina
per far soldi e il trono di canale 5
dove ha ricoperto nel logo degli ascolti
delle iniziazioni pubblicitaria no ma
stiamo ancora addosso a quella scena a
quella foto a quelli migliaia di persone
che si fermano lì che si bloccano
davanti al locale di umberto
ma perché sanno che li passerà il
cantante o che si fermano davanti alla
vita di marta marzotto perché hanno
saputo che quella sera c'è la festa
flick siamo la quella foto misuriamo non
tanto la distanza enorme che c'è fra la
famiglia di torino e di zucchero
fornaciari misuriamo invece la vicinanza
quel mondo a portata di mano
ebbene se noi la frizione questa foto se
non la guardiamo
e un'immagine senza differenze senza
conflitti che ci accomuna accomuna tutti
appunto tutti i ricchi tutti uguali
l'anno dopo questo 2 milano in cui
stiamo per entrare nell'euro e 100 si
sta se ne va perché per delle elezioni
berlusconi le vince ma come le vince
le vince stracciando i ds forza italia
arriva al 30 per cento di esse sono al
16 per cento 100 deputati in più
cinquanta senatori più le vince
vincendo dappertutto in tutte le regioni
persino in quelle del centrosinistra
conquista le le province di parma imola
prende un pezzo di lucca in toscana e
così via
al centro sinistra di rutelli rimangono
un pezzo della regione emilia romagna un
pezzo da toscana le umbre e marche e mi
ricordo ancora le inchieste dei giornali
giapponesi si sono domandati questo i
grandi analisti pure come mai era
successo all'eresia il grande voto
popolare che lascia le case della
sinistra e va nella casa della libertà
gli operai che votano false italia e
riempiono e centrano la casa del popolo
e riempiono i centri commerciali
un'eresia difficile da comprendere anche
perché quelli votavano i loro
antagonisti sociali votavano insieme
agli evasori fiscali a quelli che
volevano le mani libere a quelli che
considerava una guardia di finanza poco
meno di un'associazione a delinquere e
come vedremo di tutto avevano bisogno
queste persone meno che di un three
prassi dello stato eppure sono lì quella
foto ci viene incontro naturalmente ce
la dà una spiegazione no in quella foto
le differenze sono saltate della grande
favola di porto cervo l'immaginario
superano in realtà le differenze
spariscono per una sera siamo tutti
assieme
e così per i prossimi mesi i prossimi
anni
basta tenere alto il sogno se loro sono
ricchi c'è un motivo se e ricchi
governeranno qualcosa ce ne sarà anche
per noi le cose che avete sentito
stamattina ci hanno raccontato
l'incontrario ma tanto era forte quella
foto del resto se noi andiamo a vedere
anche i contenuti della campagna
elettorale e andiamoci assieme a quella
bellissima trasmissione di porta a porta
dove dove berlusconi vende promesse e
sogni no quello aveva detto riduzione
delle tasse con sul due aliquote
dimezzamento del tasso di disoccupazione
la critica della tensione elimina di 500
euro
che cos'è se non è la foto di porto
cervo fatta persona plastificata no
benessere e ricchezza le distribuzione
dei soldi tutti i ricchi tutti uguali
nella sconfitta del centrosinistra c'e
naturalmente di capacità del
centrosinistra c'è la debolezza di
quella classe dirigente
l'incompetenza che in parte continua ma
c'è anche la paura e il terrore che la
sinistra ha avuto e ha ancora di parlare
di lavoro povertà a salari
redistribuzione della ricchezza di usare
parole come patrimoniale di parlare di
lucky nel sangue non si vincono le
elezioni con le lacrime e il sangue non
è bello
sono belle invece le barche e le donne
che le abitano quella foto di porto
cervo è talmente forte e potente e
duratura nel tempo da spazzare e
ammutolire la sinistra undici anni dopo
sapete com'è andata a finire no quella
foto ha perso tutti i colori come un
vecchio video tape di 30 anni fa è
diventata la foto in bianco e nero del
fallimento dell'italia berlusconi se ne
va e poi e poi e poi ma che cosa è
successo da queste due foto così
distanti come ha fatto la prima a
trasformarsi nella seconda come siamo
passati dalle notti illuminate di porto
cervo alcuno bianco e nero il fallimento
perché non abbiamo percepito il crescere
della disuguaglianza come qualcosa di
drammatico e urgente che interventi
immediati come mai la forza evocativa
vorrei dire quasi terapeutica di quella
foto di porto cervo ha coltivato a
lavorare sotto traccia per tanti anni
ancora bene io
automaticamente dieci anni la mia vita a
cercare di far collimare queste due foto
a cercare di anticipare anche i tratti
poi di quella foto così drammatica
vi faccio solo un esempio dei tanti che
avrebbero potuto cambiare il destino di
questo paese e che non abbiamo messo in
atto e il 2004 sono passati quattro anni
sono a milano sto raccontando
l'emergenza abitativa
mi chiamano la mattina presso
l'associazione con cui avevo preso un
contatto il ricercato vieni subito c'è
uno sfratto in corso ci vado con la
troupe è uno dei quartieri storici
popolari di milano quelli dei primi del
novecento
ce ne sono ancora sono molto belli sono
costruiti bene e hanno l'idea dietro c'è
l'idea di una città inclusiva che se tu
vieni a milano a lavorare e fare
l'operaio deve avere la possibilità di
avere una casa e pagarla per il tuo
salario e non dieci volte di più
bene la famiglia in oggetto sono in
argento stato lì da due generazioni non
sono abusivi
c'è già un gran casino c'è la polizia
davanti c'è la gente che che ha riempito
il cortile e diciamo ci sono c'è la
famiglia rocca tali il padre sta ancora
lavorando
la mamma con i due bambini e sulle scale
la portano via arriva la prova arriva
l'ambulanza tutto il dramma della di uno
sfratto fatto in un quartiere popolare
arriva di corsa anche il capofamiglia
d'argento arriva dal lavoro del che non
è un disoccupato non è un
sottoproletario ha un contratto a tempo
indeterminato presso una tipografia un
lavoro da 1000 1200 euro al mese perché
nel frattempo siamo entrati nell'euro
così come lavorano tutti quelli che
riempiono il cortile dio ci parlo c'è il
fruttivendolo c'è l'idraulico
l'elettricista cioè l'operaio molte sono
le famiglie monoreddito d'argento e
monoreddito ed è in ritardo col
pagamento delle bollette con le case
popolari dove c'è un contratto non è un
abusivo primo campanello d'allarme
anzi direi una sirena antiaerea talmente
è grande questo campanello d'allarme
perché coinvolge il mondo nel lavoro nel
suo complesso perché quel processo di
ristrutturazione che di cui abbiamo
parlato prima
questa è tutta gente che lavora questa è
povertà da lavoro da salario 600 700 800
anche 1.200 euro
per una famiglia monoreddito da milano
significa non poter pagare l'affitto
me lo gridano tutti mentre l'inter visto
uno un muratore mi dice noi non contiamo
più un cazzo
noi non siamo più un cazzo e tutti
applaudono e questo è è l'annientamento
della forza lavoro che non ha nessun
peso politico e che costretto a stare lì
in quel cortile a difendere la povera
casa popolare dallo sfratto dei
poliziotti
naturalmente quella quella vicenda lì
poi aver proseguita ci sono stati gli
scontri scontri sono durati fino a
mezzanotte ma il popolo ha perso lì
d'argento hanno perso per sempre la casa
i poveri da salario sono rientrati con
le ossa rotte a casa loro e poi ho
seguito anche la vicenda di dei
d'argento per qualche mese per vedere se
entrava in campo qualche qualche rete
che poteva sostenere la famiglia che in
fondo non ha fatto niente di male papà
mamma e due bambini non erano riusciti a
pagare le bollette e vi dirò com'è
andata a finire questa storia delle case
popolari che vi sto raccontando è solo
un esempio delle tante politiche che noi
avremmo potuto mettere in atto per
alleviare le fatiche del popolo italiano
per recuperare qualche piccolo grado di
avvicinamento in questa forbice pazzesca
li sta crescendo di disuguaglianza è che
non abbiamo fatto abbiamo smesso di
costruire case popolari non solo abbiamo
consegnato la costruzione delle città e
gli interessi privati
nel frattempo abbiamo accettato che ci
fossero processi enormi di dismissioni e
cartolarizzazioni che per esempio nella
città dove vivo io hanno portato al a
far saltare gli affitti a 300 mila e 400
mila persone
perché questo è il dato economico e non
abbiamo pharma dc non lo possiamo fare
perché maxi che facciamo ci mettiamo a
costruire case popolari ma come facciamo
con quell'immagine di porto cervo a di
alla gente no io piattino democratico io
centrosinistra al mio elettorato ma dai
facciamo le case popolari si mettono a
ridere tutti quanti non è questa
l'italia delle case popolari ma potevamo
fare però costruire politiche di
di casa con affitti convenzionati come
ha fatto il comune di parigi
il comune di parigi e più grande
proprietario degli appartamenti di
parigi perché con una legge che ti dà la
possibilità di prelazione con compra
ogni anno 30.000 40.000 appartamenti in
vendita sul mercato di parigi e poi li
ridai in affitto in convenzione cioè con
akon affitti ma dice come fa a farlo noi
ci sfora no perché mano a mano che
diventa il più grande proprietario di
appartamenti con questa povertà riesce
ad accendere dei mutui in questo circolo
virtuoso
ecco che cosa ci ha detto il simpatico
assessore alle case del comune di parigi
se avessimo lasciato libero il mercato
due affittuari su tre avrebbero dovuto
lasciare parigi perché gli affitti di
mercato sono troppo alti noi non
vogliamo che a decidere chi video non
dire a parigi si alla speculazione
edilizia
vogliamo essere noi a governare la città
perché a parigi devono poter vivere
tutti i poliziotti gli infermieri gli
insegnanti piccoli negozianti e non solo
chi guadagna dai 200 mila euro in su se
aspettiamo che ci pensi il privato non
succederà mai
siamo noi che dobbiamo garantire la
coesione sociale strepitose no
parole da noi totalmente inascoltate
abbiamo avuto un solo esempio di comune
che interviene contro un palazzo lo
rimette a posto e poi lo ri affitta a
canone di convenzione da fatto walter
veltroni poi evidentemente non ci ha
creduto a roma e dopo di che è calato il
silenzio nomine non mi scorderò mai un
occupante elettricista anche lui a
contatto a tempo indeterminato che a
roma guadagna mille euro che stava in
affitto con la famiglia 500 euro al mese
pagava poi il contratto è scaduto il
privato gli ha detto adesso dovrei
pagare 800 euro
lui si è fatto due calcoli un amico gli
ha detto ma andiamo a occupare ha
occupato quando lui io l'ho incontrato
lui aveva fatto una seconda bambina e
questo è quello che ci aveva detto io
non so come andrà a finire se ci
cacciano via o se riusciremo a trovare
un accordo con il proprietario ma una
cosa è certa senza questa occupazione da
più piccola oggi non ci sarebbe la
gravidanza non l'avremmo ha portato a
termine questo è poco ma sicuro
parole testuali che testimoni di quanto
è diventata importante nel bilancio
delle famiglie italiane la spesa per la
casa e non è per caso che ogni volta che
attraversiamo le grandi
gli industriali dall'acciaieria e le
migliaia di persone che si sono messe in
questi anni sui tetti sulle ciminiere
perché ci stava di perdere il posto di
lavoro
il leitmotive abbiamo ancora il mutuo
della casa sue spalle da pagare come
facciamo o famiglia gridano e il mutuo
della casa ancora da pagare quindi
quanto poco lungimirante e stata la
politica per non aver lavorato per
creare degli spazi di housing sociale
nelle nostre grandi città
avremmo persino salvato le piccole
botteghe e oggi non vedremo la città di
milano e di roma senza artigiani perché
gli artigiani sono scappati perché li
comanda solo nel mercato e al calzolaio
all'artigiano gli chiedevano il doppio
der affitto una volta che il contratto
era terminato allora ecco perché io dico
e vado a chiudere fra 52 secondi con
precisione che noi che la politica una
responsabilità enorme e che il 100 si
sta c'era ancora più grande è che io non
credo a nessuna delle delle ricette
economiche messe in campo perché non
sono ricette politicamente mirate
pensano sempre che nel quadro diciamo
del gioco di mercato che la partita che
anche il popolo starà meglio non è così
ce l'hanno raccontato molto bene gli
studiosi di economisti sociologi che
sono intervenuti stamattina c'era
raccontato picchetti ci hanno fatto
vedere i numeri e bellissima quella
ricostruzione in cui si diceva bene
l'italia crescerà il 2 per cento
18 anni questa forbice rimarrà e
diventerà sempre più grande fino a che
non diventerà come è giusto che debba
essere oggetto di attività politica di
pratiche politiche di lotta di conflitto
e questo è quello che ci dobbiamo
aspettare se lo vogliamo migliorare
questo paese grazie
grazie grazie grazie